The case of Sherwood,
the walker which comes from late 19th century Michigan,
asks the question,
what happens when both parties to a contract base their agreement to the
contract on a mistaken understanding of the situation.
Mr Sherwood was a banker and he wanted to buy some cattle from Mr. Walker who
imported and bread black Angus cattle,
like the ones you see in this photo.
He went to one of walkers farms but didn't like any of the cattle there.
He then went to a second farm where he was told the cows were probably baron and
he decided to buy a cow named rose.
The second to Viber alone,
sure would called up walker and they agreed to a price that came to about $80
that five and a half cents per pound,
but when Sherwood went to pay for and pick up,
Rose Walker refused to sell because rose had turned out to be pregnant.
This is a suit for replevin that is Sherwood is claiming that Walker should be
ordered by the court to give Sherwood his namely rows the second of Ab or alone.
One interesting thing about this case is that the majority opinion and the
dissenting opinions tell the story of how sure what and Walker came to agree on
the sale.
Judge Morris for the majority says that both Sherwood and Walker were convinced
that rose was barren and therefore only valuable for her meat.
That's why the price was so low and by the pound,
a dairy cow would fetch a price more than 10 times higher around $850 and would
be valued based on her ability to bear calves and produce milk.
In this story,
both parties are mistaken about Rose Justice.
Justice Sherwood in his dissent suggests that sure would.
The plaintiff's suspected all along that rose wasn't baron.
He bought her on the hope that she might turn out to be able to bear calves and
give milk on this view at most,
one of the parties was truly mistaken about Rose's condition.
The question the court must answer is,
can walker get out of the contract now that both parties know that rose is 10
times more valuable than either of them thought?
Both of the lower courts had said no and ruled for share would,
but Justice Morse reversed ruling for Walker.
He says that when a sent to a contract was based upon the mistake of a material
fact and that mistake is mutual,
a party can refuse to go through with the transaction or even get it reversed by
the courts.
The question is what counts as mistake of a material fact?
Justice Morse gives a rather unhelpful metaphysical even Aristotelian answer.
He says that when the mistake gets to quote the substance of the thing,
the contract is unenforceable,
but when it only gets to the condition or value of the thing,
it's still enforceable.
Even if that very condition or quality was what motivated the parties to enter
into the contract in the first place.
For Justice Morse,
the question of whether a cow is barren or not gets to the very core of the
substance of what sort of creature rose is and so walker can refuse to sell her.
The question of whether a horse is sound,
on the other hand is in his view a quality or accident,
no matter that it may be viewed as essential,
uh,
to the buyer.
It isn't clear though exactly how to extend justice is Morse is distinction to
other cases.
Section one 52 of the second restatement provides a bit more guidance if the
parties are both mistaken when making the contract as to a basic assumption and
that mistake has a material effect on the agreed exchange of performances.
The party who is made worse off relative to the parties.
Original expectation has the option to void the contract.
The exceptions in section one 54 of the restatement allow for the parties
themselves to a portion the risk of mistake between themselves for the court to
decide that it is reasonable under the circumstances for one party to bear the
risk or for a party to assume the risk by agreeing to the contract knowing that
he or she is missing essential information.
These are exceptions that are important because they make the mutual mistake
drop doctrine merely a default.
While the doctrine sets out conditions where contractual duties can become
voidable,
the sellers right to void can be eliminated ex ante by the parties allocating
the risks of a particular mistake to a particular party.
In question.
Under section one 54 the parties could have agreed that the seller would bear
the risk that rose would turn out to be more much more valuable.
It still may be difficult for the parties to prove that they base their
agreement on certain assumptions,
but in a case like Sherwood,
the defendant can point to the fact that the agreed upon price clearly reflects
the going rate for a barren cow is evidence that their negotiations were
premised on that assumption.
So here's the quiz walker grease to sell.
Sure.
What a beautiful home and they negotiate a satisfactory price unbeknownst to
them.
The house is currently on fire.
Which party has the right to void the contract under restatement to one 52 sure
would walker both neither.
Well,
the buyer Sherwood can void the contract under section one 52.
Both parties are mistaken and the house being unburnt was certainly a basic
assumption to the contract without evidence that the parties allocated this risk
to the buyer say with a contractual provision requiring Sherwood to take out
fire insurance before closing.
The mutual mistake doctrine would place the risk of this basic assumption,
uh,
failing with the seller by giving Sherwood the right to void the contract
earlier suggested that formation defenses help courts police or shore up the
revealed preference inference that a contractual agreement actually increases
value.
That's one way of explaining why courts make agreement agreements voidable when
one of the contracting parties lack the cognitive capacity to know what's in his
or her best interest.
It can also help explain the mistake doctrine.
If the contractors were mistaken about a basic assumption,
it undermines the court's confidence that the contract is value enhancing.
Small mistakes aren't enough to undermine a court's confidence.
If we learn that our race horse goes a bit faster,
a bit slower than the parties thought,
the buyer still probably values the horse more than the seller.
But larger mistakes that go to the heart of what the parties were exchanging
might make a court wonder whether the buyer values the horse more than the
seller.
By making the contracts voidable,
it saves the parties from the extra burden of having to bargain their way out of
a bad deal.
Imagine for example,
that Taylor agrees to buy a used piano from Tom for $1,200 as Taylor is starting
to load the piano into her truck.
Both Tom and Taylor see that $10,000 is taped inside the piano.
Tom Sue's Taylor arguing there is mutual mistake as to a basic assumption.
Not Knowing about the $10,000 is a pretty large mistake,
but it might not undermine our confidence that Taylor is the higher valuer of
the piano.
Taylor and Tom would have contracted for a higher price,
probably $11,200 if they'd known about the money taped inside,
but the court not make the contract voidable because in this kind of
circumstances,
because there's still gains of trade
applying revealed preference.
This revealed preference idea to the case at hand in Sherwood versus Walker is
to ask whether the parties mistake was sufficient to undermine our confidence
that Sherwood is the higher valuer.
Sure,
they would have contracted for a higher price if they knew she was pregnant,
but is share with the higher valuing owner of a pregnant cow.
If sure would own the glue factory and only bought cows for the value of their
parts,
then we might think that this is a kind of mistake.
If I've corrected Dec Santi,
that would have stopped the parties from contracting at any price.
In earlier cases.
We've seen that parties must have a meeting of the minds in order to have a
valid contract.
Ensure would we've seen that the parties must meet in a place close enough to
the truth.
If the mistake they made is important enough,
it goes to the substance of the thing and justice Morris's words or it is a
basic assumption in the words of the restatement.
The parties who come to regret the bargain when they find out the truth then has
the option of voiding it.
Of course,
it may be difficult to convince a court that a particular belief was a basic
assumption or that the assumption is material,
but the big innovation of the restatement is to more clearly established that
the mutual mistake,
void ability is merely a default allocation of risks that can be contracted
around by the parties themselves.